ازاي الشركات بتستفيد من الحروب والصراعات
في مصطلح اقتصادي اسمه المستفيدون من
الحرب اول بوفتيرس ومعناه ببساطه الافراد
او الشركات اللي بيحققوا ارباح كبيره بسبب
الحروب زي مين كده زي الشركات النفط
الكبيره تخيلوا حضراتكم انهم في 2022
حققوا ارباح قياسيه وشركات منهم اول مره
في تاريخها تحقق الارباح دي الخمسه الكبار
اللي هم اكسون موبيل وشيفرون الامريكيتين
وشيل وبيبي البريطانيتين وتوتال الفرنسيه
ارباحهم مجتمعين في 2022 تخطط ال 200
مليار دولار خدوا بالكم ده صافي ربح مش
ارادات والسبب ببساطه هو الحرب الروسيه
الاوكرانيه اللي رفعت اسعار النفط والغاز
زي ما في شركات بتدمر وتفلس بسبب الحروب
في شركات تانيه بتنمو تتربح من الحروب ما
تنسوش تشتركوا في قناه المخ بالاقتصاد على
اليوتيوب علشان تتابعوا حلقتنا